[Music]
this cult is at first
only a secret fulfillment a that is a
fulfillment only in imagination not an
actuality it must be an actual deed for
a deed that is not
actual is self-contradictory
consciousness proper thereby raises
itself into its pure self-consciousness
the divine being has in this the meaning
of a free
object through the actual cult this
object returns into the self
and insofar as it has in pure
consciousness the meaning of the pure
divine being
dwelling beyond reality this being
descends from its universality through
the mediation of the cult
into individuality and thus unites
itself with reality
paragraph 716 is a
short but i would say important
paragraph
that will require a good bit of
commentary and
unpacking perhaps more so
because of what we can call some
infillicities
of translation if we want to be
euphemistic if we want to be a little
bit more straightforward we can say that
you know most of the time miller is is a
pretty good translator and i don't like
to complain too much about translation
having undertaken a lot of that work
myself and knowing how
difficult it can be but in this
paragraph
his particular translation of hegel's
german text
can in fact be misleading and give you
the wrong idea
about what is taking place so you notice
there's
a couple question marks here about
how to how to frame things and so we'll
get into that let's take a look at the
very first
sentence he says this cult is
at first only a secret fulfillment that
is a fulfillment only in imagination
not in actuality and this is one of the
first places where we have to say
all right the german text this english
translation is
okay but there's some
aspects that are being somewhat
misrepresented
so we've got the cult
the cultists that we've been talking
about now for the last two paragraphs
as a fulfillment fulbright
the act of you know bringing something
to
its its full development or
its realization or satisfaction
all of which we've been seeing coming up
in the previous paragraphs
and this has to be a kind of question
mark for
us at this point hegel is saying
what we've sketched out about the cult
in the last two
paragraphs you know
that has been an achievement but it's
not entirely
fulfilled and he says it's a secret
fulfillment right
behind us um hidden it's
it's not fully explicit so what the
participants in the cult take to be
going on
is not yet what the cult could be
ought to be is there's more development
to take place
and then we get to the you know
not quite mistranslations but
they could have been translated better
so only in imagination
nur for gestaltis only in representation
right imagination
yes but representation
and therefore imagination perhaps
or perhaps in representation
among the participants within the cult
right it doesn't all have to be up in
one's head the opposition here
is to uh actuality not
in actuality or in virtues
and since we've been talking about
language
you know for basically the last uh
four or five paragraphs here
we can say that this is probably not
just in imagination
but in talk rather than
in reality right all talk and no
do to take uh one of the epithets that
we used to have
of people who talked a good game but
didn't produce
so that's that's part of what's going on
and if we think about well what
are we going back to so in the cult um
we had this whole discussion in in 715
of the purified
soul who um you know does things
exteriorily
with symbols washing itself putting on
white robes
and then follows the imaginatively
conceived path of works punishments and
rewards the path of spiritual training
in general
think about contemporary christians and
all of their discourse about how like
they live a biblical life and they love
jesus and
you know they're they're gonna do all
these things for their neighbor and it's
basically just
on social media you know prayers and
thoughts
right that would be a perfect example of
just it just for gasteltus only an
imagination only in discourse
not in actuality if you know whenever i
encounter christians who are going on
and on about their christian life and
about when what other people are doing
that you know christ would frown upon i
always ask them
hey how's implementing the
sermon on the mount going for you are
you turning the other cheek
are you walking the extra mile are you
following all these things these
teachings that
christ laid out if not then shut the
hell up because you're full of crap
you're again all talk no do and we can
say this about all sorts of other
religions
as well this is not something endemic to
christianity
hegel is seeing this here in the greek
uh cults
right because we're talking essentially
about greek religion
although this could be extended to
really to any ancient religion so
he goes on and he says it must be an
actual deed for a deed that is not
actual is itself self-contradictory
okay and another case where you know
the translation can be misleading deed
makes you think of a single action right
that would be translated more
commonly by miller uh
that would be the word tat you know a
doing a deed
a action handled
or handling right has to
do with a whole comportment a range of
behavior
it's it's something that is a bit i mean
you can talk about you know ain't
lung as one single thing but it's kind
of a weird way
to to talk about it and so we really
should talk here about more like
a need for actual doing or comportment
and now on whose part well it could be
the cult
or it could be the individual who we're
talking about
here as well he says it must be an
actual deed for a deed that is not
actual
is self-contradictory and
wiersbrook is is the term that he's
using there
a deed that's not actual a form of
comportment this again
reinforces the idea that what we're
talking about here is not a single
action
but a way of behaving
behavior we might say
um he goes on again and says
here we go um this the divine being
has in this the meaning of a free object
now
does hegel actually say the divine being
no he just says
das vasen and who's reading
in divine being into this entire
paragraph
miller is it could be the divine being
or we could be talking about the
projection of the divine being
by this interplay between proper
consciousness and pure
self-consciousness proper consciousness
gets called pure
consciousness a little bit later so this
could be the participant
in the cult right so he goes on and he
says the divine being has in this
meaning
the meaning of a free object and free
object
is important here right so
this is this is an interesting idea
but whose freedom is it right is it the
freedom of the god or is it the freedom
of the
worshipper he goes on and says through
the actual
cult this object returns into
the self and in so far as it has
in pure consciousness the meaning of the
pure divine being dwelling beyond
reality
where does it have in this pure
consciousness
right um well this could be the pure
consciousness the purified
consciousness of the believer from
the preceding paragraph and he says the
meaning
of this pure divine being dwelling
beyond reality again it's the vasin
it's not some sort of divine being
gotlicus or you know anything like
that heiliga but he does say this being
descends from its universality
through the mediation of the cult the
culprit does
a important task that is leading
to its fulfillment hopefully
coming out of what's hidden no longer
just an imagination
producing itself in actuality
hopefully and he says it descends
through the mediation of the cult into
individuality so it goes from
universality into individuality
thus uniting itself with acts
with reality or actuality and what we've
got here
this interplay between consciousness
and self-consciousness remember
self-consciousness is
consciousness of another
self-consciousness there's this entire
interplay
of desire of lack all these things that
could be
tying in with the divine being so what
we're being offered here is a different
way
of approaching what it is that the cult
is supposed to be
doing once we get past the infillicities
of translation i think it becomes
a bit more clear what's going on
the way the two sides enter into the act
is determined as
follows for the self-conscious aspect so
far as it is
actual consciousness the divine being
presents itself
as actual nature on the one hand nature
belongs to consciousness as its
possession and property
and has the value of an existence that
has no being of its own
on the other hand nature is
consciousness's own immediate actuality
and individuality
which equally is regarded as a
non-essential being and is stripped of
its apparent independence
but for its pure consciousness this
external nature has at the same time the
opposite meaning
that is of being the implicitly divine
being
for which the self sacrifices its
unessential being just as
conversely it sacrifices the unessential
aspect
of nature to itself this makes the act a
spiritual movement because it is this
two-fold process on the one hand
of superseding the abstraction of the
divine being
which is how devotion determines its
object
and making it actual and on the other
hand
of superseding the actual which is how
the doer
determines the object and himself and
then raising it into a universality
paragraph 717 longer than its preceding
paragraph continues this
movement that we saw developed there in
fact it even uses the term
spiritual or geisteiga movement the
vague
from these both sides of what's going on
united in the act or
action the handling the behavior the
comportment
that is involved in the
cult this is providing us with an
explanation
of how the cult in fact does this
mediation that was mentioned in the
previous
paragraph and you know as usual when
hegel
is being rather schematic about things
in his prose
it gets a little confusing because he's
sort of like aristotle who will say
you know for example in nick of mccain
ethics book five oh there's two kinds of
this and then he talks about a third or
you know they'll be like ah there's
there's three kinds of this and then he
only talks about two
here hegel is talking about both sides
and he's developing them
with a lot of on the one hand on the
other hand
kind of stuff and you'd expect there to
be kind of a parallelism
there but but it turns out that that's
not the case
so um both sides enter into the act at
least that much we can start with right
uh the way the two sides enter into the
act dibida is determined as
follows and here's where he lays it out
so we've got two two sides for the
self-conscious
aspect right so self-consciousness
and then he doesn't say uh the pure
conscious aspect he just says but for
its pure
consciousness so we've got
self-consciousness
and the aspect of that on one side we've
got the
consciousness aspect on the other side
the goal is to you know bring them
together without simply conflating
or confusing them and letting each of
them make its contribution
to the big picture that is being
developed here so
what do we have on the side of the
self-conscious
aspect he says insofar as it is
actual virglika consciousness
uh the divine being and once again we
see that
you know miller is reading in here
divine
because all we actually have is the
vasen the essence the being
presents itself as actual nature now
when we see that word
actual here we do want to keep in mind
that it
is not just actually nature it is
very it is real nature it is something
before something that we encounter
something that we
experience right so the divine being
presents it sets itself
out darshtelt as actual nature as nature
that we can
engage with and experience and he says
now there's two sides to this on the one
hand
nature belongs to consciousness
as its possession and property so in a
certain sense
you know nature is the object we are the
subject we grasp the nature
it is our possession it is our property
it is something that we can do something
with
right this is a very con common concept
of
of nature on the other hand he says
nature is consciousness's own immediate
actuality
and individuality and so
yes we have nature there as something in
front of us that we can
exploit we can dominate we can do with
what we want and yet we
are also part of nature so
what's going on there is on the side of
self-consciousness right we've got these
two
aspects to it and both of them present
something as being without
um what would you call it this essence
right
not having these and unveisen leakas
right
so he says um because
uh nature belongs to consciousness is
its possession of property
it has the value of an existence that
has no being of its own
then on the other hand nature is
consciousness's own
immediate actuality and individuality
which equally
is regarded as non-essential being and
stripped of its
apparent independence so we've got this
entire side being developed
complex stuff going on in that portion
of it right
now let's look at the other side
that enters into the act the handling
for its pure consciousness again pure
consciousness the consciousness that has
been purified
the consciousness that is turned towards
the god
or the divine being through the cult
through devotion
this external nature has at the same
time the opposite
meaning or actually and gagan gazettes
you know it could be
we could say opposed we could say
you know rivaling it right it's set
against it so external nature is
what it has the opposite meaning
of being the implicitly divine being now
that is
a translation that is quite
divergent from the german text and we
need to stop there for a moment once
again we don't have divine being talked
about there we just have being
vaisen right implicit is translating
on zeke zionda right um having its being
in itself implicit could work there
but that's not the only way that that
can be
understood external nature is
we could say being that
just is what it is in itself
right it's not conscious of itself in
the way that the self-conscious
aspect is by its very name right
all this interesting stuff is going on
on the side of the self-conscious aspect
over here pure consciousness is kind of
reductive
it's kind of you know
taking things just as they are or as
they present themselves
then we get something else really
interesting going on
here as well he says that it's
implicitly divine being now notice the
next part
for which the self sacrifices
its unessential being it's
invasive right who invades league
heights i think
if i remember right just as conversely
it sacrifices the unessential aspect of
nature to itself
so something that's going on on the side
of the self-conscious aspect is also
happening
to a degree on the side of pure
consciousness the
self that is the conscious self
is sacrificing its own inessential being
to what it's stripping off its nature
it's putting on as we saw just two
paragraphs ago the white robes and the
clean body
and going through a spiritual
transformation of discipline and rewards
and punishments we saw in the last
paragraph
that this is uh you know for
stealth right it is it is represented uh
not yet made actual what makes it actual
the action the behavior the comportment
the handling
that is engaging in a very for
important form of mediation here through
the cult as we're going to see
in the next two big paragraphs that are
going to bring this
section to a close what happens here he
says
this what is this the sacrifice
the the taking something of oneself and
giving it
freely for something else
this makes the act a he says spiritual
movement because it is this two-fold
process
on the one hand now here
again translation right miller i don't
know what it is about this section but
you know i i don't like to complain as
i've mentioned but he's really
making a number of blunders here in
rendering things
this supersession this superseding
that's taking place
two different german verbs that are
being used here
one is auf haven right which we know is
is incredibly important within the
hegelian dialectic auf heibong
is this pulling something up and leaving
behind the detritus or unimportant parts
preserving
what is important within it and then we
have air haven which is not the same
thing as
elf haven they both have haven within
them lifting right
but it's it's not quite the same so we
want to be a little
careful here he says on the one hand
superseding auf haven right the
abstraction of the divine being
which is how devotion determines its
object
devotion in being devoted to the divine
being
is making an abstraction of it which
means that it's not entirely
getting it this fits in perfectly well
with talking about it as
just represented whether it be in
imagination
or in speech or in visual
depictions or things like that they're
all abstractions they're not the living
god that we're trying to be
devoted to so he says um
[Music]
taking this this abstraction and making
it
actual you know to
paraphrase a scorpion's song let's make
it real not fantasy
right fantasy is another word for
imagination
or representation we want to
have a real engagement through the cult
with the god
not just with our ideas or words about
the god
not just with an abstraction so he says
making it actual
on the other hand superseding
the actual and raising it into a
universality
right raising the actual he says which
is how the doer determines the object
and himself uh the the vehicle right
when we when we act in reality
like when we engage ourselves in this
case in the cult
with the god in whatever behavior we're
we're using whatever
uh material supports we're gonna see him
talking
in the next section about you know uh
the the animal who sacrificed the fruits
who are consumed right
these sorts of things those are
actuality we are going to supersede
those as well hegel doesn't actually use
the word
supersede of haven for at that point
it's
just implicitly there and then we're
raising it up where
haven uh that that
actuality raising it into a universality
what does that mean to raise it into
universality
it becomes something that has a greater
significance than just
my action my engagement my
experience and becomes one available to
others
one that could be shared one that could
re-enter
into language imagination
depiction and so there's this incredibly
rich dialectic
happening here in the matrix
the mediating matrix of the
religious cult
you